I took a sauna when I was in Germany and
evidently they I heard that they were
naked they go into those saunas naked
and it's co-ed so I asked furs et wanted
to go down to the sauna he said yes and
then I text him he must have fell asleep
so I said [ __ ] it I went down I worked
out got a great workout in and then I
went to go into the Sun and there was
nobody in there and the old me I like
the steam now I really like the dry
sauna cause I can get way hotter
you know Joe Rogan converted me right so
I go in there and I went in there like
an American I had my slippers on I had
my towel on and all of that [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden this dude comes
walking and he has a towel on oh my God
thank God thank God it's Berlin okay
it's brilliant
okay this is like their New York City so
everybody's gonna act accordingly and
then he just immediately takes his towel
off and I'm like what the [ __ ] so any
lays and then lays down yeah what he did
was he put his outside leg the leg
closer to me he put it up so he was sort
of covering his junk slashed looked like
he was getting ready to do recreate the
Burt Reynolds Playgirl centerfold right
so anyways and I know this is gonna be
the [ __ ] photo shop so I'm sitting
there like that what the [ __ ] all right
whatever one naked dude who gives a [ __ ]
right and then all of a sudden another
guy comes in this guy comes in he
doesn't have his towel on he's just
holding his towel in front of his junk
then he goes in like it was shaped like
a horseshoe you know like the old
[ __ ] Denver Broncos stadium back in
the day so I'm on one side of the
horseshoe I'm unlike the visitors side
then the first naked dude is on the
[ __ ] home side and then this naked
guy comes in and he lays down the same
way same Playgirl [ __ ] thing with the
outside leg up he's sitting in the end
zone seats all right and I'm like jesus
[ __ ] christ so now I'm laughing cuz
all I'm thinking is I want tell virzi
because at this point it's just naked
guys and just naked guys it's just funny
I stupid my act the naked man is either
funny or scary right if you're at a
football game and a naked guy jumps out
of the crowd and runs across the field
you're laughing you're
ass off if you're walking home late at
night then naked guy jumps out of the
[ __ ] bushes it's one of the scariest
things ever so this was just funny I'm
in a gym there's all kinds of people
around or whatever even though it's just
the three of us in there but you know I
can just get up walk out the [ __ ]
door there's no danger here there's two
naked guys it's [ __ ] hilarious
so I'm looking down at the floor and all
I'm thinking about is I can't wait to
tell Virgil this [ __ ] story they're
both laying here like [ __ ] twin Burt
Reynolds and I'm sitting in with my
slippers on and my towel you know I
don't know so anyways and then all of a
sudden the door opens again and now a
woman comes walking in and I'm looking I
kind of look at the guys like are they
gonna cover themselves up and they don't
and then she comes in and just takes her
[ __ ] towel off just like and then she
sits down in the end zone seats right so
above her in the upper deck is this
naked guy to her left is the other naked
guy she's naked and now she looks over
at me and I got a towel on and slippers
so now I'm looking like the weirdo now
I'm the [ __ ] pervert like look at
this [ __ ] guy we're all getting naked
why are you sitting over there right so
now I'm like well I gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here and just as I said that the
dude in the home seat he stands up and
he's going to walk out and I'm like
alright perfect now he's gonna use the
shower I'm just gonna wait to East down
with the shower then I'm gonna [ __ ]
walk out so that's exactly what happens
I walk out but when I walk out what I
forgot to mention was they had like you
know those ice baths that like NFL
players go to get into they had
something like that there wasn't ice it
was just like a it was a tank you
climbed up like six steps and then
climbed down into this thing and it was
freezing [ __ ] cold right after the
sauna right and just closes up all your
pores it gets rid of all the [ __ ]
toxins and all of that all the [ __ ]
washes off you grant and everybody else
is using it so it's probably [ __ ]
gross on a some level I have no idea
maybe because it's so cold it kills the
[ __ ] I don't know what so I wanted to
use it but there was no way I was going
to use it because I had to get up to the
top of it and take my towel off and be
standing up there with my [ __ ] man
who had twisted in the breeze before
went down into the [ __ ] Arctic water
but when I came out there was nobody
there so I was like I got it I gotta try
it
so I [ __ ] scampered up the ladder
quickly took my towel off and then went
down into it I was like [ __ ] it was
freezing cold went all the way up to
like my neck it wanted to stay there for
a minute but probably only stayed there
for like 15 seconds it was enough for me
but plus also I knew other people were
gonna come in and I didn't want to come
crawling out of there completely naked
like [ __ ] Jason Alexander now with my
[ __ ] junk all pulled up into me right
so the other dudes in the shower I can
hear him so now I go to get out of this
[ __ ] thing I get my towel on and
everything and I feel [ __ ] amazing to
go from that heat to that cold now I'm
gonna go into the shower it was [ __ ]
amazing so I get out of the shower now
all I want to do is tell virzi the
[ __ ] story and be like dude even a
chick came and this is [ __ ] nuts and
I reach into my robe and I can't find my
key to my locker and like where the [ __ ]
is that I drop it where the [ __ ] I'm
looking all around and I was and last
time I remembered having it I was
holding it in my hand when I was in the
sauna because I didn't want to leave it
in the pocket of my robe
for some reason I didn't see like the
band that he could put it around your
wrist
I just didn't you know I'm an idiot and
I saw I was just holding on to it and I
suddenly realized that it was still in
the [ __ ] sauna so now I have to go
back into the sauna so I go back in
there with my head down with my [ __ ]
slippers on and my towel on and I go
back in there and the naked woman is now
laying down sideways facing the door
okay laying down where I was sitting and
I'm like I can't go over there with my
towel on me like yeah hey I'm just
looking for my keys all right there
sweetheart I felt like a [ __ ] weirdo
so now I sat down she's sitting on the
[ __ ] visitor side now I'm on the home
side or whatever I might have [ __ ] up
these things you don't I mean I'm
sitting on the opposite side
was sitting on and now I'm just sitting
there going alright well she was she's
been in here for like 10 minutes she's
gonna [ __ ] leave soon
and when she does I'm gonna look for my
keys and she just won't leave she won't
leave and then finally I just have to
get up cuz I'm dying because this is my
second trip and I find when I say hey
I'm sorry I think I left my key over
here and she's like oh I didn't see it
and she's like sitting up like [ __ ]
naked right so now I go back over and I
just [ __ ] sit down I know I [ __ ] up
the story I'm sitting down there going
what the [ __ ] do I do now cuz I'm dying
a heat and then all of a sudden this
couple comes walking in and then they
both get naked so now there's two naked
women a naked dude and then me all
covered up and at this point now I feel
like a [ __ ] weirdo so I'm like well
[ __ ] I'm in Germany so now I take my
towel off and I'm just sitting there
cracking up [ __ ] laughing like you
know that you just look down and you
just you know what it's like I'm gonna
laugh my ass off but nobody's gonna know
so you don't make a sound and you don't
change your face you just have your
mouth open and you just kind of going
like I was literally doing that while I
was so [ __ ] hot I could feel my
heartbeat in my ears so at some point it
just got so hot and she wasn't leaving
and she was like a pro so I find just
got up and I just sort of had my towel
cover myself I go I'm sorry I think I
left my key over and she goes I did not
see at the Bulova and I go alright so
then I went back and I sat down that's
what I did that's when I sat down and
then she got up and I was like still
like oh it's got to be underneath her or
something so I waited for her to leave i
toughed it out and then I walk over
there and I'm feeling around on the
[ __ ] seats and [ __ ] and it's just not
there and they have the slats and I'm
like it probably fell down in between it
now I'm gonna have to walk out with just
my towel and robe on go back to the
front desk pay the fee and all of this
[ __ ] so now I walk out of the sauna I'm
[ __ ] almost passing out and to my
left and my peripheral I see that woman
again
naked at the top of the [ __ ] ladder
to go into the ice bathroom
jesus [ __ ] christ I got to get out of
here right and as I'm walking away you
know yeah I do besides I hear her
yelling over to somebody and I'm like I
know she's not talking to me and then
she just goes then she switches to
English and she goes did you find your
key and I kind of half turned but didn't
look at her and I go no no I didn't and
then she goes is this it and I realized
I had that's where I left it when I
scamper DUP the ladder to go there I
left it at the top you guys but I go oh
yeah it is
and then she stays at the top of the
ladder and just you know kind of hands
it and I walk over and literally her
vagina is above me and I kind of reach
up like looking but not looking just go
danke Schoen and it was so [ __ ] up I
didn't even take a shower I just walked
out and I went to the locker room and I
went in there and I was like pouring
sweat and everyone was looking at me
like well why didn't he shower off he's
already like the tomato anyways and then
I just I put my [ __ ] back on in that and
that there you go that's my German sauna
story but I have I got it I do have to
tell you this though if you're
completely naked in a sauna it's even
better it is even better it's [ __ ]
weird but you only can do it in a place
if everybody's naked then it isn't weird
it isn't weird and if you're worried
that you're gonna get a stiffy because
there's a naked woman in there there's
also net other naked men in there so it
neutralizes it not to mention it's hot
as [ __ ] like I don't think anybody has
ever [ __ ] in one of those hot naked
you know the naked the hot yoga class
what they call that the Bikram yoga like
you can barely survive like the [ __ ]
somebody is the last thing on your mind
when you're sitting in like a hundred
and eighty degree heat but anyways
there's my that was my sauna story it
was hilarious I was worried that my junk
was gonna look too small when I got out
of the ice bath and I was worried that I
was gonna [ __ ] salute the Germans
when I was in the sauna but I would you
know if a naked woman walked in
but it didn't I just felt like a [ __ ]
creep
so anyways and that's why you travel the
world everybody to get stories like that
you